yes but it was just four days ago where
we would have agreed we would have both
signed off on aaron rodgers one more
year with the packers and then if they
don't trade him he tries to blow it up
right and it all got accelerated and now
he's trying to blow it up and i think
we're at a point where it can be
generally accepted that's exactly what
he wants because he hasn't said
otherwise he hasn't said otherwise
there's too much out there and he's
essentially confirmed it we'll play the
clip from mike tarico in a minute but
here that's where we are in just four
days how much the world has changed for
the packers in the nfl in four days yeah
it's it is amazing you know it's amazing
just that too it seems the like the
acceleration point had really nothing to
do with green bay and rogers i think
that's like kind of the fascinating
thing too it's the fact that san
francisco called and
talked about a trade that of course blew
this thing and blew the roof off
well i think the roof was still blowing
off of it i agree well i don't know but
i don't know if i'm going to agree with
that i don't know i don't know about
that for sure that that that i can't i
can't say so
i can't prove it i have a feeling that
san francisco made that call after
hearing from david dunn or someone else
close to rogers it was worth their time
to make i'm i'm sure i'm feeling i'm
sure they know there's a lot of issues
there i mean shanahan on the floor as
close as they are i would think that you
know shanahan and john lynch had a
pretty good gauge on the temperature
of knowing that at least that hey things
aren't all you know fine and dandy there
in green bay and like t to what you're
saying mike i mean i'm i'm with you to
the fact that i think the the the roof
or the door was being blown off anyways
behind the scenes here as we go as we're
starting to read and find out more and
more to me the big thing now is just
comes down to one thing
is roger's going to go full court press
and blow the roof off this thing right
now and say screw you green bay i'm not
playing here and really play hardball
and try to get the trade done now or is
this one of those things where they're
just gonna find a way to you know mend
the fences here to just get through the
year because they know they both have a
good football team and then that'll be
it i mean that's really where we're at
right
well that that is where we're at and
we'll dig through all those
possibilities coming up for now let's
properly set the stage though mark the
packers ceo posted a periodic
q and a on social media not on social
media but on their website and it had a
fairly interesting preamble about the
aaron rodgers situation and he
acknowledges this is an issue they've
been working on for several months and
he makes it clear that there wasn't just
one trip to california to try to
unruffle aaron rodgers feathers there
have been a number of occasions that he
and brian goudy comes to gm and matt
lafleur the head coach have flown out to
california to see aaron rodgers we're
very much aware of his concerns and
we've been working with him and his
agent dave dunn to resolve them we
remain committed to aaron in 2021
and beyond well
yeah
yeah
yeah
they look forward to competing for
another super bowl championship yeah
look they're committed to him in word
they're not committed to him in contract
and that's where this all
started this was last year the trade for
jordan love
pissed off aaron rodgers i am impressed
by the extent to which he can hold a
grudge he will hold a grudge forever
and he acted on that grudge on the
perfect day from his perspective to do
it here we are first day of the draft
one year anniversary of when you turned
my life upside down i shall now turn
your life upside down so without that
contractual commitment from the team
that binds the player and the team
together for multiple years
that that's where the packers wanted to
be year to year year to year we want to
have the flexibility if aaron slips to
go to jordan love and trader aaron
rodgers and rogers wants more and i feel
like the windows closed on the
opportunity to get that commitment to
get the commitment in contract and
that's that's why we are where we are
now i think the draft was the unofficial
deadline remember when russell wilson
gave a deadline to the
seahawks mid-april start of the
off-season program gotta have my new
contract two years ago and they acted
and they got it done i have a feeling we
haven't heard this reported yet i have a
feeling aaron rodgers and his people
made it clear you got until the first
day of the draft to fix this and they
didn't and here we are well i mean here
we are uh
you know
there's there's there's i don't even
know where to begin with this talk i
mean okay so what where are we gonna go
from here i mean i that that's that
that's the big thing i don't know the
contract situation hey are the packers
going to
invest more than one year
of you know guarantees or being linked
to rogers for more than one year to me
that's got to come down to that right i
mean i would think it's about what two
years three years something like that is
rogers gonna do that at this point i
don't know i mean i don't know if green
bay's gonna do it but rogers isn't gonna
sign on with green bay if it's just
gonna be like hey you made me happy for
one year and then
maybe
i come back for the second year
with some security or is it still going
to be that type of situation where it's
like well there's a little security but
we could get rid of you
and yeah we take a good you know dead
money hit to our football team but you
know we could still do it that's rogers
is not going to play ball with that he's
not he this is crazy territory we're in
crazy territory
you know again i got no there's no one
to blame but green bay here they drafted
a quarterback and traded up in the first
round when they had one of the five or
six best players in the league playing
the position of quarterback
now he is
the two or three best players he's mvp
of football
so
this is unprecedented territory to where
they don't want to commit to him he
wants a commitment
and
we're at a stalemate and that's where i
just i don't i don't think roger's going
to go for it i think they've burned the
bridge too much here i have a feeling
that rogers is going to be like that's
it it's over i want to get the hell out
of here and and we're just going to see
that happen here sometimes in the next
month or two
that's why i think he gave them three
months to try to maybe you're right and
the solutions that they have
that they have proposed right and i'm
told they've offered him an extension
right they've offered him the security
but i think at a certain point you got
to pay me more than jared goff i think
that's part of it too it's not just
you you tie your hands contractually for
the next three years it's beyond that
now he wants an apology whether it's
financial or whether it's more than that
but before we get to my thoughts on what
i think he wants and what he reportedly
wants
let's hear from mike tarico from
saturday's coverage of the kentucky
derby he had a chance to talk to aaron
rodgers who declined to speak on camera
but he spoke plenty to tarico here's
what tarico said
and i bumped into one of the vips here
just happens to be the biggest news name
in sports right now that's aaron rodgers
we've heard of the story of green bay
what's going on with aaron he's here
with his fellow fiance shalene woodley
here this weekend he didn't want to talk
on camera i can tell you i characterize
aaron as disappointed that news has come
out of this rift with the packers he
expressed a couple of times how much he
loves green bay loves the fans loves the
franchise
there is a fish there is a chasm between
management and the reigning nfl mvp
we're just not sure how this is going to
play out i'll watch closely over the
next couple of weeks to see what we hear
from the packers side and when aaron
does speak
a fisher a chasm
that's the words that might use and i
think it accurately reflects where
things are
and it's very difficult to repair a
fissure it's very hard to bridge a chasm
when the bridge
has been blown up chris and that was
stunning and
aaron rodgers does nothing accidentally
nothing happens coincidentally
accidentally happenstance it's all
concocted it's all planned it's all
strategic and and i admire him for that
this isn't criticism
it's just a way to understand how we got
to where we are and the only thing that
i think is funny about what taurico said
the idea that rogers is disappointed
that news of this no he's not
disappointed that news of it came out he
made sure that that and rogers i'm
saying made sure that he professed love
to the fans into the town because he
does not want them to turn on him even
though i sense that some of them are
starting to
but
that was the that was the the message
from rogers
basically he is done
and i don't know what they can do at
this point to change his mind i think
it's too late i think the battle lines
are drawn and now we see how the packers
handle this we saw how the texans
handled it and they were just about
ready to trade deshaun watson before
the legal issues arose for watson back
in march
will the packers warm up to the idea of
trading rogers between now and the start
of the regular season or i guess maybe
the trade deadline if he stays away it
really could be cars and palmer 10 years
ago where a broken collar bone for jason
campbell opened the door for the raiders
to give up too much for carson palmer
and and that impasse could it be that
rogers just sits and waits and waits and
waits and waits weights indefinitely for
the packers to decide to do something i
think he's the kind of stubborn slb that
would do it i'll just say that you know
i mean just you know just a a read of
not really knowing a guy
and just watching them all those years
and of course you know yeah financially
the money he has just the kind of person
he is i do think he's willing to draw
that line in the sand and kind of be
like screw you i'm not coming back we'll
see where it goes i mean anybody you
talk to in the nfl this has been
percolating since the end of the
football season there's no doubt about
that green bay has obviously known this
has been going on and rogers is not
happy i mean hey at base level the fact
that they
they don't organizations don't fly
coaches gm's presidents
of their organizations to go see the
quarter act multiple times
multiple times one time is an absolute
holy crap catastrophe one time is
there's a catastrophe we have to get on
the plane when we're going multiple
times and a three round you know go
around here with three different people
that means we're beyond catastrophe that
means it's holy crap he's told you to me
it just looks like he's told you there's
really no way i want to play for the
football team anymore and then they
continue to go to hope they can inch
away at the conversation to finally get
him back to like okay he's at least
thinking about coming back but you know
i i won i'll tell like
yeah i mean he's held a grudge i think
you're right he's held a grudge
he played awesome football he had to see
brady win a super bowl and play like
really average to beat him in an nfc
championship game and then go there and
then when so you see that
and then he gets to know guarantees off
of that mike and here's one thing that i
i will continue to go back to that i
think is going to always piss him off
is the fact that he was so blindsided by
the trade last year that to me is
something that's jumped out a lot during
this process because uh just because of
shanahan and the 49ers here they are
tr we're going to try to trade you and
draft somebody they've let jimmy g know
every step of the way what's going on
he's jimmy g they don't have to tell him
crap no one would care no one would make
a big deal about it they didn't even let
rogers have an inkling a clue and i bet
you that pisses them off a lot too sorry
for talking so long there no that that
that's an excellent point because i
think that is one of the reasons why we
are at the point of no return and it's
one of the reasons why
this happened when it did there was a
quote
from brian guticunes to peter king
in which the broader message is they got
one trade call this weekend for aaron
rodgers and and that makes sense you
can't you can't build
a trade like that
in an instant it's going to take some
time it's going to take some thought and
everyone's otherwise focused on their
draft boards and
goodacoon said and this stands out to me
you never want to see those things or
read those things he's never said that
to me and never said that publicly that
relates to something we're going to talk
about in a second regarding goodikun's
future at the same time i'm a lifelong
scout and we work all year for these
three days we couldn't let this distract
us from the task at hand
that's a nice way of saying i am pissed
off this is brian gudekunst i am pissed
off that i settle in for draft weekend
and i'm trying to make this team better
and i got to deal with this
i got to deal with this crap
as i'm getting ready
to try to go out and find the players
that will make this team better
i got this guy
all of a sudden
throwing grenades into the nest as we're
trying to figure out how to make this
football team better are you kidding me
if i'm gonna close i'm livid yeah and i
i i appreciate him taking the high road
because at this point being upset with
aaron rodgers and making it known he's
upset with aaron rodgers is not the way
to fix it
and on top of everything else
on top of the distraction that comes
from the news that aaron wants out
that lands on draft weekend the report
from charles robinson of yahoo sports
that rogers
king of the grudge
king of the north king of the grudge
give him the belt
all-time grudge leader he wants gudekuns
fired according to robinson that is a
grudge i don't agree with it but that's
a grudge
yeah it is a grudge there's no doubt i
mean uh you know again
i don't know what to say
about
you know whether he wants guten coos
fired or not i'm sure he doesn't like
him i mean of course he doesn't of
course he doesn't especially if he got
you know surprise attacked
you know kamikaze style last year in the
draft for him so yeah hey rogers rogers
yeah throw grenades whatever i don't
know it was a grenade it was a
full-fledged bomb that was thrown on
friday or thursday night by the rogers
camp i think they've been throwing
grenades all off season and they've been
throwing them up there but i also don't
think rogers gives a damn he doesn't
give a damn he's got he's like you said
mike he's thinking about last year's
draft going grenades bombs you threw a
nuclear weapon over at me i mean so he's
going this is just fair fighting and you
know again i i mean i'm with you mike i
guess in my heart of hearts you're right
the the information came out about
rogers more and more i'm guessing from
rogers camp i think the information and
everything is going to get out though to
a degree this weekend no matter what
with the fact that the 49ers called
green bay and did that and then rogers
somehow knew of the situation so there's
just too many ears involved in that for
that not to squeak out by somebody and
you know yes then i think probably
rogers leaked some other stuff out or at
least his camp to you know apply the
pressure even more greatly chris
nothing you say is going to change my
mind on the fact that this was all
orchestrated and planned and i think
they manipulated the 49ers into making
that call knowing that that would be the
first domino to fall on what became an
avalanche of news all aimed all aimed
at at exacting this vengeance on the
packers and if i'm a packers fan and i'm
trying to figure out who to be upset
with here i agree with you preliminarily
i'm upset with what they did last year
i'm upset with with number one
using a first round pick and the fourth
round pick that was packaged with it to
trade up on a position that is not a
position in a position that they're
still not going to be able to throw that
guy out there this year they still can't
right so go ahead if if all goes as
planned this year he'll stand on the
sidelines the entire season right again
with a team that's 13 and three two
straight years and really could have
benefited from that first round picking
fourth round pick that's how it got
started but if i'm a packers fan and i'm
trying to apportion blame here you
mentioned the numerous trips and how big
of a deal it is because rogers is so
upset right these these guys have other
things to do in the offseason they've
got free agents to evaluate they've got
contracts to negotiate they've got
they've got film to watch they've got
and yeah on the flight they could talk
and they could meet and you can
multitask but the idea that i got to get
up today at 5 00 a.m
and i got to go over to the airport and
we're going to fly out to california
because we got to go kiss aaron rodgers
butt again when i got other stuff to do
right there's a point where it does keep
you from being as effective as you can
be yes there's a point where it does
there's a plan
okay and then when you get ready to to
take make your draft picks that's when
he drops the nuclear bomb when you're
trying to focus if i'm a packers fan i'm
getting upset with aaron rodgers right
now well i i understand the turmoil he's
causing the team well
there there's a point yes he's turmoil
right now but but but but but but but
but but
i mean come on
this i don't care we go back to the
start of the route of the problem did
mike if we were told this was going to
happen before the draft last year you
would have gone
oh aaron rodgers going to be pissed oh
this is going to be great tv i mean do
they not know what they were dealing
with because we did
we knew what they were dealing with we
knew what was going to happen yeah okay
well now they care oh oh because right
but chris
so it's this is still their issue
two wrongs don't make a right
learned that when i was five very good i
still don't necessarily i still don't
necessarily practice it
but i learned it when i was five and
look chris
let's compare and contrast
what did deshawn watson do
the minute the season ended what did he
do made it known i won out yeah didn't
wait didn't wait three months
didn't wait for the perfect time
to sabotage draft weekend for the texans
and drop that on them put it in any
other context with any other player
if my any other player my homes russell
wilson anyone who's done it or hasn't
done it to have all that drop on you as
you're getting ready for the draft that
is the act of someone who is calculated
strategic and he doesn't care
what damage he does to the organization
you know why he doesn't care because
he's never playing for him again that
that's the message well especially if he
gave him really was if if he really was
invested in staying in green bay he
would not have gone out of his way to
screw things up for them
on draft weekend which is what he did he
went out of his way to throw them off
killed her on draft that's what brings
me back to what you said earlier on i
think that yeah i think when you get
back into your like draft weekend was
the week like we had to get stuff done
i i i you know the more we peel this
back and talk about this and the things
i've heard from people around the league
over the weekend and things like that i
mean they've known i think he put them
on notice since after the year he didn't
make it a public thing i don't know why
maybe he should have i'm not trying to
say that's right or wrong
but i think at a base level we know
they've known since then so this must
have been the line of demarcation or
whatever else and it didn't happen so
now he's going scorched earth without
you know actually saying he's going
scorched earth which i think i know is
what actually pisses you off more than
anything is the fact that he just
doesn't go all in on it and own it and
everything like that
well it's too late he owns it yeah this
is this is the involuntary tattoo that
someone you know he got blackout drunk
and someone took him to the tattoo shop
and he got the tattoo going streaking
through the quad he can't he can't he
cannot make it he cannot make it go away
at this point and he had a chance he had
a chance to say fake news or whatever
else he wanted to say could have gone on
camera with torico and said it's all
phony it's all fake i love green bay i
love the packers i'm not leaving he
confirmed it all yeah and then he he
talked on camera for five minutes with
twin spires
and the issue never even came up how do
you how look look i i am not a trained
journalist
but how do you agree i'm if aaron
rodgers says to me i'll talk to you for
five minutes but you can't ask me about
my situation with the packers and say
aaron thanks but i can't i can't do it i
can't talk to you for five minutes on
camera i look like bozo the clown if i
don't bring it up with you on camera and
someone eventually will agree to that
and and you know yeah that happens
i've said no i've said no to interviews
in the past when they say well you can't
ask about this and sometimes it's
something i wasn't even going to ask
about anyway but don't put conditions on
me just don't do the interview if you're
if you're not enough of an adult that
you can't handle that question that you
don't have an answer for it because you
know you're going to be asked it that's
on you that's not on me and how could
you talk to aaron rodgers and not
and not
wander into that territory when it's the
biggest issue in all of sports over the
weekend it really did hijack the draft
it real look look we're this is the
monday after the draft we've spent 25
minutes talking about it because we want
to yeah i i know well he's a huge star
there's no doubt about it and i don't
know you know you agree to those terms
when you're some tv network that i've
never the hell heard of you'll just go
what do you want to talk about aaron
writer sure whatever you say we just
want to have you look like a buffoon it
makes you look like yeah sure it does
though and i'm not afraid to say it it
makes you look like a pack of idiots
that you agreed to talk to that guy for
five minutes without asking him about
his situation with the green bay packers
it was like an alternate reality he's
all happy and he's like his name tag
said turd ferguson which i have to give
you like that you like that i like that
a lot yes i like i love that but uh yeah
it's it's like it was it's like it would
have been if he had a five-year
extension fully guaranteed with the
green bay packers and there was a
certain amount of acting i think on his
part i mean it's got to be chewing away
at him of course he wants his thing to
be resolved yeah of course this is his
life i mean it's not resolved it's the
last few years of his career he didn't
envision it going this way he didn't
envision like playing at a high level
and then being an mvp and like feeling
like you know
he's not supported or has any security
or that he's like not on a one-year deal
that's how he feels he's the mvp of
football and he feels like i'm on a
one-year deal like
what do i have to do i have to go out
and prove it like i gotta prove it to
make the team next year and he's saying
screw that so that that's it and you
know again last week
mike i said remember early last week
when we were talking and i can't
remember exactly what we were talking
about but i was like this is they don't
have to worry about there was a contract
stuff remember i said they don't have to
worry about it he won't be there next
year
i i had already heard enough things
around the league to know that things
were rocky i didn't expect it to happen
i didn't know i didn't realize it was
like the critical like that that's what
i was getting to you're right i didn't i
didn't realize that so that's that's
now i'm sitting here going like you i
just think well it's just a matter of
time it sounds like he's gonna dig in
and they're gonna dig in for a while and
we'll see if somebody comes to the table
and makes some big time offer to get
aaron rodgers
i think if we're smart enough to realize
they were manipulating him and they were
trying to get him just angry enough that
he goes out and plays at an mvp level
but not so angry that he upsets the
apple card he's smart enough to see it
too because he's smarter than we are and
he saw that he's being manipulated and
he's blown it up he's blown up their
plans you're not going to play this game
with me i played it in 2020 and i went
out and had an mvp season after you
pissed me off right i'm not doing it
again right and this whole fire goody
koontz thing couple of things on that
one
i i think he's out of line well we don't
we don't know this yet like i mean
charles robinson reported when charles
robinson put his name on it if he he
talked to somebody in rogers camp who
told him that's good enough for me okay
he wants gouda kunst out and it fits the
profile that i've compiled over the last
10 years on aaron rodgers would he want
the guy to be fired yes he would based
on everything that's happened but i
think there's a couple of problems here
beyond him being out of line for wanting
it number one
goody koontz may just be the messenger
for mark murphy i think mark murphy's
the puppet master here so if you want
goody koontz now you want murphy out too
that may be the unspoken part of this
and the other reality of it chris and i
was writing something about this before
the show and i'm going to finish it up
when we're done
the fact that they don't have an owner
we've talked about no owners absolutely
fights too this is where it's a problem
to be fired or gm needs to be fired it's
a problem now hey there are good reasons
to not have an owner who can meddle in
everything there are bad reasons and i
have an owner who can solve problems now
there is no one in that organization who
can unilaterally without worrying about
what anyone's going to think on the
executive committee the board of
directors the shareholders there's no
one there who has the unquestioned power
to fix this without regard for future
consequences and you can't hold that
person accountable if it's mark murphy
right now you can't make them do
anything right now all you can do is
later deal with it later if it ends up
being a giant mess if everything blows
up and it lingers that's when
shareholders can uprise that's when
board of directors can start asking
tough questions that's when executive
committee can launch a coup and murphy's
out but it's nothing that can happen
right now it's nothing that can be fixed
right now by anyone other than murphy
and there's no one who has the
unquestioned power to say this is what
i'm going to do this is here's what i'm
going to do we're going to trade jordan
love today you know no we're going to
cut jordan love today we're going to
give aaron rodgers a five-year fully
guaranteed contract and we're gonna
we're gonna uh
yeah i don't know that again i'm not i
don't like even saying it but an owner
would have the ability to fire brian
gudykoons if the owner wanted to yeah
this is what it this is what it takes to
keep the most
successful popular important figure in
this organization here i'm gonna do what
i have to do i don't have to worry about
anybody telling me otherwise differently
that that's what they don't have so they
can't fix it the way that other teams
could right now if they wanted i agreed
that's where like the owner's business
acumen and just their ability to people
skills all that maybe foresee the storm
that's coming when he's sitting in the
meeting rooms and hearing his gm about
to trade up you know to get a
quarterback that's i i mean i agree with
you that's where the owner is very very
valuable uh there's no doubt about it
and yeah i mean again i'm i'm with you
as far as like it's not a great look for
aaron rodgers to be like fire or guten
coost or whatever else it's not you know
but again i think the way he's looking
at it he's going well the guy wants me
fired i mean he's trying to fire me so
he's he's you know yeah petty as it is
again back to your two wrongs don't make
it right uh yeah it's it's not a good
look but you know he's frustrated
there's no doubt about that we see it
this really does have its roots and this
is the message for every other sports
organization out there
you can't drop bombs like that
without giving the guy a heads up and
maybe they were afraid to give him a
heads maybe maybe maybe no one wanted to
be the one to tell him right it's like
telling raquel welch she doesn't move
her arms enough when she dances no one
wants to be the one who goes in there
and gets beaten up by aaron rodgers for
being the messenger of we're trading up
for your potential replacement so it's
not just how they handled it it's the
fact that they did it yeah
you can't
do it you just can't do it and i
understand they'd love to replicate what
happened with farv to rogers and let's
hand the baton from rogers to someone
else because they had they had 20 long
years
of of not good football between bart
starr and don mikowski they got a
glimmer from don mikowski and then they
got brett favre but the packers in the
70s and the 80s
they were laughing so they were pitiful
they were horrible yeah and they want to
avoid that and they they may get that
now
because they overplayed their hand as it
relates to the final years
of aaron rodgers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports